you were originally you are from Detroit
born and raised in Detroit yes I born
and raised it but you but you have some
Detroiters I live you live in New York
now though yes I did yes yeah so here's
a delicate I have a delicate question
you have been spotted around town any
Yankees hat yes yet you are from Detroit
yes how did that happen okay I
understand I understand we're both in
the American League and I get it for any
of the Detroiters out there but my
girlfriend born and raised here in New
York she's a New Yorker through and
through she because of her great love
for me has worn Detroit gear and it
didn't burn right so the least I can do
is try putting on a Yankees cap which I
did and it fit very well yeah so so
we've gone to some games this year and
what's that John John laughs yeah he
left up here Joe so yeah we got in his
helicopter and he's gone so we yeah so
we've gone to some Yankees games this
year and they were fantastic and and and
it's just it's the people here I love
the people here in New York so much I
can't I can't I feel like
like you guys are like the great the
greatest parent what a wonderful
adoption I thank you so much because I
said no I just walked down the street
and it's it's lovely it's just lovely
it's everybody very shy boy and I just
say Poli it's usually Paulie go along
with Paulie it's only you'll go you'll
be fine I'll be fine but it's like Paul
were you and that yeah it's just like I
love yelling at people on the street and
not getting in trouble it's really good
all right it's fantastic you know you
were at a Yankees game I have to say you
profess now to be such a great New York
or and you love New York you did the
most dead sold dead-eyed version of the
YMCA dance ever I think we have a
picture of it right here here is no you
look you look like urinate you look like
you're in a hostage situation and you're
doing as you're told
I here's the thing I'm a very precise
person I wanted to make sure that the
fingers were not too unalloyed yeah
because I didn't want anybody to hate me
and I'm not even quite sure there
actually there is no oh in YMCA I don't
know why I'm doing that yeah what is at
the beginning of my yeah am I doing here
oh that's my a okay but you did do the C
backwards yeah yeah you put I didn't go
to school in New York
[Laughter]
you